Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Fortnite Battle Royale.
Now, they just released a new game mode called "50v50,"
which literally means you pit 50 players against 50 players in fortnight
Which is kind of a Pub G clone not 100%, but pretty much, and then when you go to the island
There's a bunch of crafting that you can do while you're also trying to fight to survive
So I'm gonna go in here probably suck probably die my team is probably gonna lose, but bottom line 50 V
50 mode is stupid fun
Imagine if you had just a huge bunch of your buddies all not able to talk to each other
But somehow hive minding your way into building bases
Killing other players and just beating the snot out of each other all day long, and then you cannot have what 50 v 50 is
And if you want to give an idea about the game it is pretty much pub G. Can't jump off into the ocean
This game's stupid, and I hate it, so we're just waiting to get on the bus one thing
I like about it the wait time to get on the bus: way
Way way way better
Alright, so this is the battle bus and I'm not in a squad because I don't want them jabbering in my ear about it
But I'm not in a squad and in the future
I may play this with Bob and Wade and whoever else wants to play but for right now
I kind of gotta just take my time and
I don't know. I just kind of got to take my time and hope for the best
Oh, boy.
Ooh.
All right, so same ordeal
I've gotta- I have to glide my way down
And I don't know where my teammates are all gonna go until they land
Now all 50 of my teammates could be anywhere on the island which means that I could land in the middle and have nobody
And die horrible death which is exactly what I'm probably gonna do because I don't see anybody I see nobody
I got nobody by my side
Anybody? I'm gonna go the other side of Loot Lake for some reason and kind of like
Rambo this and by Rambo this I mean, I'm gonna be the guy that Rambo usually shoots and die like
Instantaneously. There's something in the middle- There's something that loot lake here. No no so the trick is
if there is a trick to this game to
try your best to
Smashing roofs because that's where all the loot is
for some reason not honor of censure
Why anyway lap flappity Boop but a flap loop so ignore the squiggly nature of this. Oh good nothing
That's excellent. Oh boy, so you just the pretty much the premise is pretty much
Everything is destructible in this world, and you just make do with what you got and you that's a trap
But not a gun if I don't get a gun in this goddamn building. I am so unbold good. Oh pistol
perfect
Exactly what I was hoping for okay. There's something here
that sound means that there's something probably a chest of some sort in this room ah
Ah goody goody gumdrops, that's a little marginally better. Okay, where's my team?
I am very far from where I need to be I am very boned. Okay. Let me oh well
That's not what I meant to do all right. Well. It is what it is, so
All right well I got a gun got some ammo got bandages
And I got no hope so let's make our way to the circle because it's gonna be like pub gee it's gonna close in on
Me and I'm gonna die well. I just
Alerted everybody to my position, and I am very slow through this Marsh. If anybody spots me. I'm good as dead
Are you just walking
in the lake
Sticking out like a sore thumb. Let me step. Yes. Yeah, yeah, this is the good stuff. Yeah, this is still the mood everybody
Okay, so I don't know oh god. I must not be close enough to be able to find my teammates, so that's a problem
If you don't get close you're gonna be dead
And I looks like I'm gonna be dead my teammate my team is not doing well 27 to 38. Oh I am
Just boned. I am so I am so unbelievably
Boned if it was a measure and a scale to put how boned I am
I can't describe it because it's off the charts of how much bone Ridge. I'm currently in oh
Boy, I think my team is getting annihilated left, and right, which is never a good sign
Boy, I'm so bummed
I'm so bummed
Well technically speaking. I'm in the circle, which is okay. I guess not great ooh. What's dead a
shield potion cuz that makes sense sure why not
Yeah, I don't understand how shield potion works
like
Some kind of magic going on there is that just like energy being except pure radiation being put into my bones
He's probably not a good thing okay 24 to 34, and I'm just a lone wolf out in the middle of nowhere
Oh-oh store my shrinking
Well the good news is no one's gonna expect me coming from this direction the bad news is they've got 34 people which
Isn't really good odds. I'd say usually that ends up with me being dead on the road again
Out on my own and on the road again. Who's that a teammate? Oh, it's a teammate
Oh out on his own do I found another Rambo? Well, that's that doesn't bode well for me, but
well
Well here that
Are you at Oh?
So here's the trick of this thing?
You can build up
And
Shit oh wait here we go got it nope didn't get it Oh criminy Christmas
Crime any crap miss its oh geez oh boy. Okay well
Alright hang on. Oh this is embarrassing
Well, this is the worst type of embarrassing there. We go alright. What did I get nothing? This is not worth my trouble yeah?
great, okay
Alright, well moving on
Glad I stopped for that shit alright. What are we looking at ooh? I got some teammates over here even though
They're probably not gonna survive, but I might as well join up with them because my survival odds go up. Exponentially if I don't
Go on my own. I'm just a walking bag of ammo for anybody that kills me, but okay
We sat on my lot in life. At least. I don't have to reach too high try to exceed my own goals
I know exactly where I'm gonna be and that is in the realm of suck
And if I'm along this river at least my body will float down and feed some of the wildlife
That's all one can really hope for so where the hell are the rest of the team. Oh good. They're coming to us
Oh good. You know how I said good. I actually meant not good the opposite of good the anti good
Maybe I could hold this bridge. I guess
I'd be a thing I could be the bridge troll no one shall pass Oh
How I've been downed no my ass
Cheese alright well like I said, I was a walking loot trick couldn't even kill that one guy
Oh, this is going badly for us. You know what I'm gonna. I'm gonna leave this match
And I'm gonna try this again that one that wouldn't didn't go well right off the get-go
So let's hope that there's more hope for me later. All right. Let's see this a little differently
I'm actually gonna get some teammates in my squad and hopefully
I'm not gonna die immediately because it won't be on my own and no one will love me
Probably not good news off the bat Papa chuck is
Disconnected which is always great. Okay? All right. Let's do this. I don't know where we're going, but okay now
That is a thumping bass all right so the question is
Well my teammate already launched well die
And that doesn't bode well for me oh
Boy, my squad is across the entire map from each other. That's always good. I like that oh
That's an enemy player that's also an enemy player ah I've boned myself, I will leave
Excuse me. I must my people require me excuse me man
You can go fast and far away. Holy shit
Okay, all right. Well. I'm here now boyo Ewing ooh. That is an epic something
Bow your Union what is this magical device I'll slap cheese
Hey guys, I got slurp juice
I don't know what that did but uh I'm feel real Slurpee guys. I feel right as
Slurpee whoa hey hey come on now. Wha wha what's going on here? Oh?
Well, that's just rude. No you no no no no no no no
asshole
Well my slurp juice did me a whole lot of nothing Oh
Amazing now
Great two gigantic teams face off nearby teammates are marked in green after they've landed
I don't know where my team is going default and
A good day to YouTube. I was like when people are polite right off the bat cool Assad
Don't worry me too. I'm patently terrible at this
Yes
Oh, hell yeah
Oh
Shit I already jumped
Oh, you know same ol same ol not too bad
Happy birthday
Nah, I just usually prefer to have anything yeah, any gun
Hey, I got one down
Nick I may need support. Where are they currently at Oh my boy Nick dead Oh?
Nick dead all right. Oh, yeah the girl in the house with a shotgun
Thunder door and she was there something got me. Oh my apologies Nick
I wish I could have saved you you seem like a nice person
Yeah, what a rough happy birthday
Indeed I wish you luck in your next game now
Well if I stay in this game will it be possible to reconnect with you guys?
Oh, no I was too far away to help
I
Send you friend requests or may as well do squad or something
Hmm. Oh, yeah, you send me one right? Yeah, I did in - markiplier - oh
Thank you. I'll look into that as soon as I'm dead which will probably be soon
I don't know about that would you happen to be?
I can neither confirm nor deny any such insinuations. I would say yes there well
Sounds cool to me. I do check a lot of a YouTube page about video game and stuff and your voice does sound familiar oh
I don't know. Maybe I just got one of those voices the voices every people
Yeah
We got a whole bunch of teammates just over at loot lake for some reason I'm not sure why
I
Said I hate you for that. It's it's the one thing. I can't stand I'm a incredible racist oh
Really, yeah, just a true fact about me. Sorry. I tried to be honest about my racism though. It's just keep it open
You know that way everything's fine. Hey, I'm white
No, no, I'm racist against pretty much. Everybody anybody. That's not explicitly Miam racist against
Yeah, I hate everybody so you're kind of dr. House
Yes, that except racist. I want to emphasize on my incredible horrible racism
I
Can neither confirm nor deny my Texas upbringing
Okay apparently I made some friends, so that's nice. It's someone's birthday, and they're hanging around even though
They're dead, and they're terrible teammates, but whatever it's all good
Since you're saying that you hate everybody except you
I guess you would be the kind of guy who would put a bullet in the back your buddy
Well, that's awfully presumptuous of you. No no I may be a horrible races, but I'm no murderer
Opal tell the difference well, I'm saying actually the game. No, I was talking in real life. Yeah
Yeah, it just started. I don't really know anything about it destroyed the 50/50 mode was here
And I thought I'd check it out, so it seemed pretty fun
You're still alive
surprisingly
Yeah, you know we'll see how that luck holds out, I imagine it won't
because our team has seems to be down a few you saying you're not gonna pull one v30 I
Wasn't planning on it I believe
Hmm, I don't believe in me
I don't believe I don't believe in me at all no no way that's in addition to my incredible racism
I have crippling self-doubt I have no self-confidence
What's at whatsoever, but the way you do speak you actually sounds like yeah, you know those kind of voice which are overconfident
Yeah that does sound like me
Ow my dome got Shack Oh
From the right ouch ouch
No no no they they seem to be focused on themself which is obviously a priority in my opinion Oh
Oh
Save yourself Oh, No well, that's not good
I'll block your bullets with my body my body my beautiful body my body oh
Yeah, we're dead, okay, all right. I'm out. See you guys. I'm recording a video. I gotta keep going all right
Bye, aren't they delightful happy birthday to whatever his name was I wasn't even paying attention to that. I'm good to try again
Let's do it again
All right another game another game Wow okay? I just watched them die
All righty, then who's on my team who's not on my team who?
And where are we gonna go?
doodly-doo
doodly-doo I
Just put down a marker. I don't know if anybody's actually gonna go for it, but nope my teammate is gone. Not that way
Okay, all right well kills is gonna go for the Rambo kills which I can respect Hey
Okay, all right we got him we got him calm down calm down calm your murderous rage filled potion
For some reason out who did the ow what?
Potion no my ass. My ass. How did you get how? Did you oh my god?
Mannix god damn it. I'm dead like an asshole
Is that what I am dead like an asshole and there's kills off on our own?
Find another match I got to win one of these
Man the first two games I played before I started recording
I was doing wonderfully in a Rick rag everything went great and everything was super fun, and happy and now not so much
Enough not so much
I'm gonna do this again. I got this
Don't kill me I want to specify. Oh boy here. We go era. What are we gonna do everybody?
What's going on? Ah I like it I can grew I can grew and see with that. Oh, yeah
Ah
The good shit
Man you really glide
you
Really glial. I'm about to hit a bridge. Nope going right through it apparently whoa okay, all right, then oh wow
Okay well that's nowhere can I get a gun can I get a gun oh? Yeah? I got a gun all right?
Well, I got a gun that's a thing got two guns one's not good is the other gun but I got something
Okay, all right you can have that go for it go for it get it
teammate that I care about
That I care about the survival of ooh. They're your shiny
Okay, I know how to get to you. Oh wait. No. I don't have any materials. All right. I'll do one of these maneuvers
Come on
Sheíll potion
Okay, we are far away. All right. Well at least I got a gun
That's good. If only I could do something about that all right autobots roll out indeed
Let's see where we're gonna go for this what am I elven eyes see?
Nothing probably enemies hmm smart meeting up with more of our day mates. I see ah yes
Excellent I
too will smash up this car for raw resources ah
Yes, I see who's up here, okay?
Thought I heard somebody ooh tomato town all right. That's weird who built this okay?
Got a move on I guess
I don't like it see it's like a balance you got a you got a like one get guns
But also like took for the endgame you also got to get like enough raw materials to be able to build
Walls and bases and stuff like that to be defensible and on the move and all that shit
So if it was like super strategic team battles where everyone could actually communicate with each other
Which they can't you know?
They'd be like hey you gig you guys go gather and you guys go scavenger who got who got shot talk with supreme? Oh?
Talk about supreme. Where are you?
I'll try to get you. Oh, he's always so far off
Always in fatal fields. I can't get him in fatal fields. That was his stupid idea for going all the way over there anyway
What a dummy?
Who okay it's getting down to the wire the teams are actually evenly stacked this time around so it's still anybody's game
It's not just defined right off the bat. Well. We shall see pretty sure teammate build this whoa why he should have jumped
Good old loot lake huh good ol loot lake?
Okay, okay. We do have a lot of teammates over here, which is nice
Whoa shit. That was my bad. I scared everybody didn't I?
oopsies Oh
Scarecrow on this guy ah I was beautiful. Okay, looks like we're assembling our squad over here
I see a bunch of them over there
Which is good that bodes well because that means that we or I'll gather enough together, and we finally assembling
As Bush I'm gonna take this instead oh
Damn it. I meant instead not with you. I got too many guns
It looks like the the team is moving this away
we're all I know we're just waiting for the next circle to see where that's gonna be because
Depending on where the circle is is either gonna mean. We cross the lake or we're that we're gonna have to camp over here and
Rinky-dink oh we gotta cross the lake yeah, Pleasant Park. This is gonna be the death ground
All right, I'm down. You see I got a lot of wood
Our guys are getting picked off, but also their guys are getting picked off
So it stands 28 to 22 our team and I haven't done shit, so whoa where whoa who did that?
Well I don't like going up this big thing, but you know I am a follower, so I'm gonna follow up or also
I'm gonna be stranded
You cock ass who did that son of a tit son of a bitch tit?
Son of a titty bitch all right fine. I don't need you you think I need you the answer is I do not need you
Because I have my own way to go
Don't box me out. I just built that I asshole. What are you doing?
We're doing a douche f2 there. We go now. We're looking like we got a thing we know what we're doing about yeah, that's
That's that's the good stuff. Oh that is the good stuff
Wait no no wait man. Wait wait. Oh god. I didn't mean to do this one I
Forget how you can't sign. Oh god damn it you asshole who did this?
All right wait O'Hara edit this put a door in there there. We go. Okay. Got it
Let me build you some chests. I walls friend all right well
See this is the cool thing like suddenly everyone just starts slapping a tower together like gather nowhere
It's just like all right this I decree. This is where our base. She'll be and nobody decided anything
I don't know where they are, but I have a funny feeling they're setting up on the other side which would be devastating
Boys this is gonna be a doozy oh
Shit, well this base is all bunk. We gotta go forward
That's what I'm gonna do see my thing is I just like to build as I go up. Just to create like
barricades and fuselage
Naughty otters and fancy words just because I'm like we've got hit big guy Oh
What big guy go down? I don't know who cares there's only 20 of them out there
Yeah, I just walk out and suddenly there's barricades everywhere
That's ingenuity right there. That's ingenuity. Okay. This is weird. Where are they where are
They by all accounts we should see him. Huh cuz we're trying to get the high ground which is smart. Oh
That's not good. That's close to me. That's very close to me
Whoo that's very close to me?
All right, what do we got? What do we got? What do we got?
What do we get guys trying to take shots or that's definitely one of their bases?
Well there they are
woooh
We're losing we're low on beeps with low on beep is's there's a lot of shootin happenin
Okay, I'll try to get down there try to help this guy yeah, no one shooting me, please no one Jew me
I'm a hero. I'm a hero right now
up and Adam
Who's shot me
Ah above us, Oh how'd they get above us so quickly oh boy? Oh boy?
No, I wasn't paying attention to the storm if it I just run for it they would have been Oh, No
Oh
Seven vs. Ten I gotta see how my team does... ughhh!
I didn't do shit. I didn't do shit that round was a terrible run. Oh no, oh no  what a tough fight
tough fight oh
Man everyone just tries, it's who's that everyone tries like no matter what everyone tries. Oh boy build the bold
Spastically the power to create
shit Anand ed
Hi, des gee won. The game. I just tied as g1 the game that doesn't make any sense at all that seems unlikely whew?
I
Have no money. Oh, I'm in the game
That's the other thing matchmaking a lot quicker in this one which is nice
But they don't have a zombie mode which is bullshit cuz I love zombie mode alright. Where are we going I?
Agree, oh, well. This is gonna be a tough squabble oh
Yeah ooh, this looks like an important gun whoa hello
Okay apparently I found everything so if I die this time around I am an asshole officially like unforgivably
I'm a dick if I fight fuck this up somehow, okay
I got to meet up with my teammates, so I got a shotgun an assault rifle
That's apparently legendary or something and a sniper rifle whoa and a submachine gun
That's always good and let me drink my whatever the fuck this slime slug slime is okay apparently
I've got I got decked out with absolutely everything you could possibly get in some of the best equipment Bar None and
Somehow, I'm gonna find a way to fuck it up and die I know that for a fact
I'm not gonna die to this circle. That's for sure, but it looks like our whole team is in this town
Which is lovely? I just got to make sure I find everything I need
ammo wise because if I don't
Then all of this is for an thing anyway. Shouldn't be the first one to go over there
Oh, I'll be the first one to go over there. Okay. Here I go
Let's arrange on this scope oh
That's nice. That's real nice
I'm not the best sniper though, but here. I go man. This guy's gotta move
We're we got we got to get to the circle. Okay. I made it into the circle at least that is something
See if I can get some high ground oh
Come on oh shit one shot, ads I'm okay I get it
Well that's okay, there's a drop to it, Oh
Almost gotcha just moved it just moved well I can
Damn yeah, this is these are long shots. They'd have to be standing like Stockstill oops
Okay only one bullet left on that one. So that was a waste. I didn't hit anybody, but it felt good
So that's what matters. I was a good engagement for our bros. I guess
Oof looks like we're just annihilating the other team this can't be good
Man, I want to get at least one kill prove that I'm worthy and whatnot god damn it
They're just making me run the whole time
All day every day. Okay? Oh
Boy, oh boy. Oh boy. I don't know if I'm gonna make this I made a detour that was probably a bad idea
I'm gonna make it. I'm gonna make it. I'll make it
Come on. I just want to be in the battle. I got all these good guns, please, please please to be
No no my good guns
Boy oh
Boy oh, man that was
Dicey Wow six health okay? All right, then I have six health
six health oh
Boy, but I gotta kill, so that's good. I almost died doing it, but hey. I got a kill
Oh
Snuck that shot in there. Oh hell yeah, I never it was pure luck but Oh
Alrighty then hey did everything quickly oh
That guy had an epic sniper, but hey that was good
I didn't use any of my amazing guns to the best of my ability, but hey, I still wanted it felt good
So thank you everybody so much for watching. I hope you enjoyed this. I'll probably play this again with my buddies
Ahhh! just as soon as they're free
But I just want to give it a try to give an idea of it before I get into it with them
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know anything down the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video